we are continuing to follow the
aftermath of a house fire in north las
vegas today
started last night off pecos and
cheyenne two kids were pulled from a
home and today we've learned that one of
them
has died bianca holman is live now with
the very latest hi bianca what a sad
story
screams could be heard coming from this
house on
webster circle you can see the door
still charred there from the flames
they were screams of a girl calling out
for her brother
i spoke with george and sonia mcginnis
who lived next door sonya says she heard
the screams and immediately told her
husband
george looked out the window saw the
smoke ran out the door calling 9-1-1
the couple says they tried to calm the
eight-year-old girl and george attempted
to get inside propping the door open to
help
get the four-year-old out it was a
traumatic night for everyone involved
i wasn't thinking i was just trying to
get into that damn house and
it was just too much i just pray for the
family
i pray for the family and little girl
she did everything she could do
she was amazing i'm very proud of her
she did
everything now the cause of the fire is
under investigation
the few of the neighbors tell us that
they did not see any adults at the home
of the time and
that the fire and flames were seen near
the laundry and kitchen area of the
house
now no word yet on the name of the child
that has not been
uh released just yet and the red cross
is assisting the family
at this time reporting from near pecos
and cheyenne bianca holman 8 news now